the jurogan experience they developed
these suits for people to wear around
bears out of these bear suits they're
like these big metal suits with spikes
popping out of them have you ever seen
any of that
see if we can find those what's that for
they're bear proof suits they've
developed these yeah well i think
they've
developed i think they started out in
siberia i think this one you was wearing
it does look like 2500 that's a siberian
bear hunting suit no so they literally
developed a suit that's covered in
spikes so that if the bear tries to bite
you it hurts his teeth wow
i mean you gotta have to ask that dude
but since we have his jacket i doubt
he's alive
you know
i guarantee you that's gonna be that's
gonna be a yeezy outfit in six months
it was literally i i wasn't joking when
i said i look at his jacket
oh that's hilarious oh this was he when
he was on stage with the mask on yeah no
he had a stacking cap he had a stocking
cap on his face that is what he's
wearing he's wearing a bear hunting
jacket wow wow
that is crazy and that jacket probably
cost three thousand dollars yup
thirty thousand yep
that is what's so crazy is they gonna
buy it too joe of course they will and
they gonna buy that i keep telling black
people i say kanye is rich he's a
[ __ ] genius y'all can't walk around
united states being black with that [ __ ]
on your head like you got to rub the gas
station if kanye had food stamps black
people would buy it for three thousand
dollars a pop not me
connie is an unusual human have you ever
met him no his brain is firing at a
different rpm than everybody else's
he's just going like he's probably
simultaneously thinking about new
products while he's thinking about new
songs while he's thinking about he wants
to reimagine housing he wants to build
houses he wants to like develop like
communities that are there are
self-reliant communities where they grow
their own food and use solar power and
the dude is just constantly going with
new ideas constantly they're like it's
like a he's like you know
there's there's people whose brains just
don't work at the same speed as ours
right and that's one of those people and
he's just constantly trying to process
things and he was saying that when they
tried to get him on medication they were
like listen you got to get on medication
like they tried to calm him down but the
medication made him he he started you
know
yeah he kind of gained a lot of weight
he looked different he looked slow he
looked unhappy exactly and you know like
he i mean he it was a droopiness to his
face and i remember the black community
like what the [ __ ] is kanye on yeah
you know medication but then when he got
off of it he came alive yeah i don't
know why he put the stocking cap on his
head
but i guarantee you're going to yeezy
across the top and you're going to see a
whole bunch of people with ski masks
in jail
[Laughter]
well in this day and age where everybody
has to wear a mask that's the solution
in his mind that ain't the solution for
us
did you see kim was wearing one too yeah
she was yes she wore one too the whole
deal her kids were like what the [ __ ]
are you wearing mommy
you don't pay three you don't pay three
thousand off of your makeup and then you
got on ski cam i wonder how many people
are gonna wear those bear hunting suits
around now now people gonna buy them a
hundred people come back
if he makes them they'll buy them
well when you like an artist you buy
them look i'm not even beyonce size but
i find myself waiting on the ivy park i
can't wait [ __ ] but beyonce's shoes she
dropped but i thought myself wait no ivy
park to drop some [ __ ] you hear me i
have four phones and a laptop going i
got to get me a pair of avid part shoes
when kanye came on the podcast before he
came on
there was one point in time where he
wanted to redesign my studio
he's like i want to redesign a studio i
want to do it somewhere else we're going
to redesign i was like okay but then
uh jamie got coveted jamie was not there
for the kanye interview unfortunately
so he uh so we had look man we just lost
our producer we got to do it in our
studio so he did it in
in here in our old studio but he did not
like it he did not like the aesthetics
of the old studio like his mind is
always thinking about design and and
when he told me this i was like okay and
so then all of a sudden we're on
facetime he starts showing me sketches
that he already has of the new studio
that he wants to design
he's making a studio like a womb like
this big crazy studio here this these
wild ideas like his brain is on it's
like he's on jet fuel just constantly
going
but that's why he can do all the [ __ ]
that he does it's not a normal mind he
had two listening parties and st did he
drop the album yet i don't think so now
he still ain't dropped and people well
what the [ __ ] can you it's like crack to
him now yeah but that's what he does he
gets everybody excited about things he's
a [ __ ] genius yeah watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify